[Applaudissements]
mise en scène et motivation des troupes
à l'américaine comme les recettes de
cette marque implantée depuis 30 ans
outre atlantique sur le créneau du
burger premium traduisit haut de gamme à
base de produits frais est dans une
ambiance fun en français cuisine ouverte
personnel invité à faire le show pour
les premiers clients déjà là une heure
avant l'ouverture bonne surprise ce sera
gratuit
retrouvez leurs burgers préféré s'en
aller à paris ou aux états unis
ça c'est l'autre bonne nouvelle quand
j'ai appris ça ça ça m'a vraiment étonné
parce qu'il ya plein d'autres grandes
villes où fergie n'a pas présent donc
que maintenant il ouvre son restaurant à
dijon c'est vraiment bien et voilà du
coup je voulais je voulais vraiment être
dans les premiers à goûter feuilles
grises à dijon nous voulons nous
implanter dans toutes les grandes
métropoles régionales de france et puis
après c'est vraiment les opportunités de
sites qui guide nos choix
la toison d'or est un centre commercial
régional et donc j'étais un choix
évident pour nous dijon est le dixième
restaurants en france le troisième
or paris la marque en vise 40 fin 2019
autre option pour cette franchise née à
lyon il ya trois ans le centre ville
près de la place de la république une
ambiance bistrot des produits français
un gérant issu d'une famille de
restaurateurs dijonnais nous travaillons
qu'avec des acteurs locaux que ce soit
pour le fromage comme pour le pain qui
est cuit chef chaque nuit pour le
lendemain
au niveau du positionnement on est
vraiment sûr
une action locale et nous voulons
vraiment rien que sur du frais et d'une
maison on voit la viande qu'elle est
différente on l'apprécié en bouge le
pain c'est pas le pain va pas dire les
noms des concurrents mais bon non je
laime stand guerlain clin d'oeil ici
tous les burgers s'appelle marcel cerdan
comme le boxeur pagnol comme l'écrivain
à jackson bon ben là c'est presque comme
le chanteur